et pour parler de ce secteur de
l'aéronautique nous sommes avec xavier
titel mann consultant aéronautique pour
cgi business consulting bonjour monsieur
vous aviez thilleman la cgt a estimé que
dans de nombreux endroits la crise du
coronavirus était un prétexte pour faire
des compressions d'effectifs imposé
également des baisses de salaires est ce
que c'est ce qu'il se passe actuellement
dans le secteur de l'aéronautique
le secteur de la rue dit qu'il est quand
même particulièrement touché personne
peut dire qu'ils font semblant d'être
dans une difficulté qui sont majeurs on
a les compagnies aériennes qui ont eu
des revenus qui se sont effondrés qui
était de zéro pendant plusieurs mois et
on a la construction aéronautique qui va
se diminuer de 40% pendant plusieurs
années
aujourd'hui on imagine un retour à la
normale autour de 2025 à 2028 selon
certains scénarios et donc jusqu'à 2028
peut-être qu'ils auraient besoin de
produire aucun avion parce que la flotte
qui est déjà disponible que ce serait
suffisant pour assurer toute la
croissance qui est prévu jusqu'en 2028
alors qu'avant on avait une croissance
qui était prévu à 6 % par an d'une année
sur l'autre et donc un doublement du
trafic tous les 15 ans là aujourd'hui on
est à moins 40% de production ça va
s'établir sur plusieurs années ces accès
uniquement le renouvellement des anciens
avions qui va être continuée notamment
dans des compagnies comme air france qui
n'ont pas annulé leurs achats alors que
beaucoup l'ont fait mais du coup
évidemment il ya trop de salariés par
rapport aux besoins
et je pense pas que l'aéronautique fasse
semblant d'être dans de difficultés
c'est vraiment une réalité
la particularité de l'aviation c'est
qu'on est soudée mais tellement
technique que forcément on essaie de
sauvegarder l'emploi par exemple et des
gens il leur faut cinq années avant
d'être formé par exemple pour câbler
certains circuits hydrauliques ou les
commandes de vol et ces gens là
évidemment on va les garder mais on
n'imagine pas qu'on va se séparer de 40%
des usines au contraire j'ai plutôt
l'impression qu'on a une sauvegarde de
l'emploi qui est supérieur aux besoins
alors pour revenir justement à airbus on
sait que les carnets de commandes sont
pleins
ça ce sont les propos de la cgt 7600
avions auraient été commandés ils
doivent être fabriqués pourquoi
finalement l'avionneur propose
aujourd'hui un plan social
tout simplement parce qu'effectivement
on a un carnet de commandes qui est très
important mais il ya aucune compagnie
qui souhaite aujourd'hui recevoir ses
avions dans la mesure
elle exploite pas déjà sa flotte dans dé
manière normale on espère cet été au
moins d'août avoir 40% des vols qui sont
assurés c'est à dire qu'on est toujours
à -60% les compagnies aériennes qui
avaient une projection de croissance de
5 10% par an par exemple
wizz air qui avait une croissance qui
était incroyable qu acheter des airbus
tous les ans elle a plus de l'un de ses
avions et pendant plusieurs années elle
a plus besoin de voir cette croissance
donc toutes les commandes qui était
prévu de réceptionner en 2020 2021 2022
ils en ont plus besoin donc la
production des avions elle simplement
décalé plusieurs années effectivement
les carnets de commandes sont pleins et
normalement on avait des livraisons
prévues jusqu'à la fin de la décennie
mais une partie de ces livraisons qui
vont être décalés de plusieurs années et
aujourd'hui les avions qui sont produits
à une certaine quantité qui attendent
sur le parking et de la même manière il
ya certains avions qui sont produits
pour des compagnies qui sont en train de
faire faillite et qui annulent leurs
commandes et vous avez par exemple
easyjet qui est un gros gros acheteur
d'airbus qui veut simplement à lille et
ses commandes en tout cas il y aura plus
aucun de livraison dans les prochaines
années le plan social d'airbus ne
concerne pas seulement la france il
conserve également l'allemagne
on sait que 1500 emplois pourraient être
sauvées ici 2000 en allemagne
pourquoi voilà ces chiffres sont plus
importants justement en dehors du
territoire français
alors j'ai pas une explication de la
répartition exacte
après il ya aussi un poids de la france
qui est plus important dans l'aviation
et dans l'aéronautique et chez airbus et
air que logiquement on avait une
répartition qui étaient équivalentes
entre airbus et boeing alors qu'on a
quand même relativement plus de salariés
d'emplois en france qu en allemagne donc
à peut-être aussi cette répartition qui
se fait de ce côté là il faut savoir
aussi qu'à une certaine quantité de
support de soutien de marketing de vente
de ressources humaines qui sont gérées
plus tôt en france qu'en allemagne
et là quand on regarde des vignes
peut-être que ça va être l'équivalent
dans les deux pays
par contre les fonctions supports qui
elles aussi sont fortement impactées
pour sa traduction de l'emploi sont
plutôt française et donc c'est peut-être
aussi ça l'explication c'est qu'on se
contente pas de détruire des emplois
dans les cols bleus dans l'évier
mais aussi tout le côté cols blancs et
là c'est la france qui est clairement
dit dans ce domaine là comme l'a indiqué
bruno le maire un ce matin sur europe1
l'aéronautique bénéficiera de
sur de soutien massif selon vous est-ce
que cela pourrait relancer l'activité à
moyen terme
de toute façon pour produire des avions
il faut bien qu'ils aient compagnies
aériennes aient besoin d'avions et tant
qu'elle ne voleront pas clairement elles
n'auront pas besoin d'avoir d'acheter de
nouveaux avions
le plan de relance il permet par contre
de préparer l'avenir il permet d'assurer
de la recherche fondamentale et la
recherche pour aller vers un avion qui
serait neutre en carbone à l'horizon
c'est excessivement ambitieux mais
évidemment airbus peut-être en ce moment
on n'avait plus réellement l'argent pour
investir et faire ses recherches et donc
c'est l'état qui investit ça nous
permettra d'avoir un airbus qui sera
toujours champion dans dix ans quand on
aura le besoin de nouveaux de produire
des avions
par contre à moins que l'état achète
sans avion demain
l'état n'a pas réellement de pression
l'état peut acheter des avions
militaires peut faire un certain nombre
de choses sur la maintenance ou des
hélicoptères par contre les azzurri
nîmes qui représentent la majorité de
l'activité d'airbus à part investir pour
avoir des avions vers demain il n'y a
pas réellement d'action que l'état
puisse faire merci beaucoup vous aviez
quitté l'allemagne d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant aéronautique pour cgi
business consulting